Roger what brings you here tonight I'm
here to support my friends were part of
the cast and crew and Kamal Haasan sir
who's the director and you know the lead
actor in the film is one of my idols
growing up in India and he's one of the
reasons I am an actor today in Hollywood
and I'm also working in on some projects
in Chennai and Bombay in India and it'd
be such a dream come true to work with
him in the future and so I'm here to
support all the cast and crew and all of
the hard work that's gone into making
this film and it's the beautiful you
know Pacific theatres and the grow be
kind of hangout place in LA for family
so what other actors come to you for
advice and they say I'm in a lull in my
career can you show me what I should do
to kind of drum up work for myself what
do you tell them you know it depends on
the type of situation they're in you
know I think it's a difference between
being active as houses it's usually when
you wait for things to happen that
you've come across those kinds of
difficulties but you know the way that I
approach it is the same thing I tell
them is to you know create work for
yourself you know if you're good at
writing write something and get it
produced whether it's a short film or a
feature film whatever size of the
project it doesn't matter you know
entered into film festivals things like
that so that you have the recognition
going for your work and it also keeps
your artistic you know kind of energy
alive so that's one of the things I tell
you know friends or even you know
mentees you know people who come to me
for advice is to is to be proactive and
create the work for yourself
and lastly you know couply Hassan has
such a loyal fan base and and he's
really like royalty yes in India do you
feel the same responsibility because
Indian cinema seems to really just put
their their actors on a whole nother
level than maybe America does with their
actors I do feel that sense of
responsibility for sure because you know
representing the Diaspora the community
that we're part of we're not a very huge
community we're about 1% of the US
population so we're certainly a minority
but we're a minority that's achieved a
lot you know everything from you know
advisors in the White House to the
governor of Louisiana to you know
activists in in politics and in the you
know in the public health space in in
society and you know I feel privileged
and blessed to be able to represent them
you know I do play a lot of doctors
which is the common stereotype you know
amongst Indian you know professionals
and you know but we've done well for
ourselves because of Education and hard
work and I feel very privileged to
represent them and I feel that
responsibility definitely and and you
were so right you know Kamal Haasan sir
is a superstar in India you know he is
idolized you know like like no one else
and you know it's such a dream to be
able to work with him in the future
because he set such a high bar for
himself with the quality of filmmaking
he does and he pushes the Technol in a
technological envelope in terms of
hiring people from Hollywood to come in
and do special effects and stunts and
you know all these things and it's just
a pleasure to watch his projects
and I grew up with his work as a kid in
India and you know he's definitely one
of the reasons I'm an actor today so
he's a he's a huge inspiration to me
thank you appreciated so much